[Musique]
en 1950 pour tester les capacités
cognitives des machines qui aurait une
propose de tester leur capacité à avoir
des comportements indiscernable des
comportements humains
c'est ce que turing a appelé le jeu de
limitations que l'on appelle désormais
le test de turing
alors on pourrait rétorquer qu imiter ce
n'est que faire de limitation et qu'il
ne s'agit donc que d'un test
d'escroquerie certes
reste que pour devenir un bon escroc il
faut tout de même acquérir deux sacrés
compétences je l' ai appris tant bien
que mal en essayant d'imiter les
nordmann cyprien et autres miquel launay
pour devenir youtuber ou pour essayer de
danse est assez correctement
quoi qu'il en soit ce principe
d'imitation est aujourd'hui au coeur de
l'architecturé du plus spectaculaire des
réseaux de neurones à savoir les réseaux
de neurones générateur adverse à rioz
aussi connu sous le nom de générative
agresseurs networks ou guys et les
gagnent c'est vraiment un truc de fou
kelis c'est un truc de malade
[Musique]
en particulier il ya un an nvidia a
demandé à son gagnent d'imiter des
images photoréalistes de célébrités et
voici les performances du gan pendant
des heures et des heures
le gan créa de toutes pièces des
imitations d'image de célébrités sauf
que ses imitations représenter du coût
des célébrités fictive inventé de toutes
pièces
voici deux images de célébrités l'une
d'elles a été fabriquée de toutes pièces
par le gan de nvidia
laquelle est ce selon vous est-ce
l'image du mec ou de la fille
je vous laisse répondre dans le sondage
à l'écran et que ceux qui connaissent la
bonne réponse se taisent pas de spoil
dans les commentaires ok mais comment l'
architecture des gannes permet tel
d'entraîner les gan affaires de
limitation et bien l'idée c'est comme le
nom l'indiqué d'introduire une sorte d'
adversaire aussi appelé discriminant
plus précisément on aura un réseau de
neurones générateurs en charge de créer
des fake imitant les images
photoréalistes et un réseau de neurones
adverse arial en charge d'aider
l'imitateur à déterminer ce qui fait
bien et ce qui fait mal donc en fait
l'adversaire n'est pas vraiment un
adversaire
on pourrait voir cela comme un
enseignant ou en critique bienveillant
quoi qu'il en soit générateur et
adversaires forment ensemble un réseau
générateur adverse arial google mais
bien sûr pour que l'adversaire puisse
émettre des critiques sens et il lui
faut apprendre la différence entre les
images authentiques et les imitations
l'apprentissage du gan se décompose donc
en deux phases d'abord montre plein de
données authentiques et fake pour aider
l'adversaire à distinguer les deux puis
l'adversaire dit aux générateurs comment
ces images doivent être modifiées pour
davantage ressembler aux authentiques et
l'astuce technique pour permettre cet
enseignement personnalisé du générateur
par l'adversaire c'est l'algorithme de
rétro propagation oui parce qu'au bout
du réseau adverse arial il y a en gros
une note qu'il dit à quel point le fait
qu du générateur ressemble à une donnée
authentique et c'est cette note pour ces
faits que le générateur à vouloir
augmenter la rétro propagation permet de
remonter les gradients est de savoir
comment les activations des neurones
observable de l'adversaire doivent être
modifiées pour améliorer au mieux la
note que vraisemblance en
interconnectant les réseaux adversaire
you est générateur on peut alors
remonter les gradients au niveau du
générateur qui pourra alors mieux
déterminer comment modifier ces
paramètres
et notamment ses pois synaptique pour
que les images qu'ils génèrent soit
aussi indiscernable des authentiques que
possible donc si je récapitule l'idée dé
gagnent c'est d'entraîner un imitateur
en lui fournissant des gradients calculé
par un adversaire qui a appris à noter
le niveau de ressemblance entre un fake
est un authentique
plus précisément l'adversaire calcul une
probabilité que l'image qu'on lui donne
soit un fake et on l'entraînent à donner
des probabilités adéquate en pénalisant
la perte logarithmique moyenne quand on
lui expose aléatoirement des fake et des
authentiques
c'est lié à la divergence calme et je
garde ça pour une prochaine série
bon ça c'est l'idée globale mais bien
sûr il faut s'attendre à ce que le
générateur s'améliore et à ce que
l'adversaire devra ensuite ré apprendre
à distinguer les authentiques des
nouveau fake
en fait le gan consiste à alterner des
phases où l'adversaire apprend à
distinguer les authentiques défèque du
générateur et où le générateur apprend
ensuite grâce au feedback de
l'adversaire comment rendre les fake
plus indiscernable des authentiques et
de façon stupéfiante
ce procédé tout simple a permis de
concevoir des réseaux générateur capable
de créer des images photoréalistes de
célébrités que les réseaux adversaries
auront bien du mal à discerner des
authentiques que ces réseaux adversaires
reçoit des réseaux de neurones
artificiels ou des cerveaux de primates
et tout ça ça marche déjà super bien les
applications sont à la fois nombreuses
et stupéfiante en exploitant la
sémantique profonde que les réseaux
générateurs en viennent à créer à la
suite de l'apprentissage lagan dispose
ainsi d'une sorte de représentation
adéquate de l'ensemble des données qui
leur sont exposés vue-là qui leur permet
par exemple d'augmenter de manière
spectaculaire la résolution d'image très
pixélisé on peut également appliquer les
ghana l'édition automatique d'image qui
consisterait par exemple à gommer
certaines parties de l'image que l'on
trouve moche par exemple est demandée
hogan de reconstituer les images sans
ces trucs moches
[Musique]
les gan permettent également d'imaginer
à quoi ressemblerait un paysage données
observées dans d'autres conditions
météorologiques
et puis de façon plus stupéfiante encore
légales peuvent nous faire danser et pas
juste danser comme un idiot mais même
dansé avec la même posture et le même
rythme que les danseurs professionnels
bon malheureusement je n'ai pas réussi à
trouver le code source du guen qui fait
ça et c'est bien dommage car j'aurais
bien aimé une image de moi qui danse de
façon non ridicule bref avec les gagne
de nombreuses applications stupéfiante
inimaginable il ya quelques années
semble désormais à portée de main comme
la création de vidéos fabriqué de toutes
pièces qui peuvent faire faire et faire
dire n'importe quoi à n'importe qui
[Musique]
obama yes we can reduce dynamique et oui
tous ces trucs trop cool pose également
de sérieux problèmes d'éthique mais bon
je pense que vous commencez à comprendre
à quel point ces problèmes mouscron
du coup je vais laisser ça de côté pour
aujourd'hui pour le reste de cette vidéo
la question qui va nous intéresser
c'est la suivante est ce que cette idée
de réseau adversaire you est vraiment la
bonne façon de faire du machine learning
après tout ce que je vous ai présenté
jusque là ça ressemble davantage à une
liste d'astuces d'un générique à une
théorie solide
est ce qu'il est possible d'affirmer
qu'en un sens assez fort
les gagnent sont la bonne architecture
voir l'architecturé ultime pour faire du
machine learning
alors tout d'abord il est bon de
signaler qu'une propriété remarquable
des gan qui est différent si d'autres
architectures notamment c'est le fait
que les gagnent sont entièrement non
supervisées autrement dit pas besoin
d'étiqueter les données pour permettre
au gan de bien fonctionner il suffit de
données hoogan une énorme banque
d'imagés authentique
vous pourrez trouver sur des tas de
sites comme pique sa belle les gars ne
se chargeront ensuite du reste toute
seule
ok les gars ne font de l'apprentissage
non supervisées mais est-ce à la bonne
manière de faire de l'apprentissage non
supervisées qu'est ce qu'on veut
vraiment faire au final quand on
effectue de l'apprentissage nous
superviser et même de façon plus
générale encore qu est-ce qu à prendre
aux caisses qu'à prendre aujourd'hui
cette session fascine toutes sortes de
chercheurs les informaticiens devraient
rendre leur algorithme intelligent
les philosophes aimera garantir la
fiabilité des sciences et les étudiants
aimerait valider les examens sans aller
en amphi et là je ne peux m'empêcher de
citer l'un de mes grands héros le géant
reis l'aumône of je cite en sciences mon
intérêt concerner davantage la manière
dont les choses étaient découvertes que
les contenus des découvertes l'oeuf doré
n'était pas aussi excitant que loi qui
les condamne les contenus de découverte
saignant mais effectué aurait effectué
des découvertes
c'est tellement plus floue et le génie
de solomonoff fut de découvrir le moteur
des découvertes en combinant
l'algorithmique avec une étrange
philosophie appelé le bail à nice mme
pour les adeptes du bayer zanis mme
apprendre c'est ni plus ni moins
appliqué la formule de bise en
particulier cette version de la formule
de bayes qui nous invite à calculer la
probabilité des théories sachant les
données et là c'est le moment historique
que vous êtes sortir pour la première
fois du youtube internationale ma
casquette bayésienne sauf bien sûr si
vous avez respecté mon livre vous savez
sans doute aussi que cette merveilleuse
équation est horriblement dur à calculer
elles mêmes
en un sens précis incalculables du coup
il nous faut nous contenter
d'approximations de cette équation pour
commencer la première approximation que
l'on va faire ça va être de ne se
restreindre qu'un an
ensemble de théories qu'ils sont gentils
en un sens c'est à dire des théories qui
seront faciles à manipuler algorithmique
morts et comme vous l'aurez compris il
ya beaucoup de bonnes raisons de penser
que parmi les théories les plus gentils
on trouve les réseaux de neurones
notamment parce qu'il se prête très bien
à la descente de gradient via la rétro
propagation en fait plus précisément on
va considérer toutes les théories qui
correspondent à une architecture de
neurones fixé mais dont les paramètres
peuvent varier
il reste alors à trouver les bons
paramètres et pour cela ce qu'on va
faire c'est en fait chercher les
paramètres qui sont les plus crédibles
au vu des données
c'est à dire celle qui maximise la
probabilité de la théorie sachant les
données on parle de maximum a posteriori
hockey et donc pour déterminer les
paramètres et le plus crédible d'après
la formule de bèze
il nous faut déterminer celles qui
maximise le produit de la probabilité
des données sachant les paramètres par
la probabilité a priori des paramètres
bon je vais pas énormément rentrer dans
les détails mais la probabilité a priori
des paramètres ça correspond à la
régularisation de l'épisode 18 est bon
on va un peu l'ignorer pour aujourd'hui
il nous reste alors plus qu un terme à
considérer qui correspond vraiment à la
capacité de la théorie ici le réseau
générateur a expliqué les données
c'est-à-dire dans notre cas la banque de
données d'image ou de vidéos ou autres
et bien dans le cas des réseaux
générateur la probabilité en particulier
d'une image ça correspond à la
probabilité que le réseau génère
exactement cette image pour comprendre
cela il faut que je vous dise que pour
générer une image
le réseau générateur prend une graine
aléatoire qui correspond à une
activation aléatoire de certains de ces
neurones initiaux et applique ensuite
les calculs basique des réseaux de
neurones dans un pareil dans l'épisode
41 pour générer une image
et bien si on répète le processus
générateur avec plein de graines
aléatoire le réseau générateur finira
par générer exactement l'image donnée et
bien le temps que ça prendra six ans
grohl inverse de la probabilité de
l'image donnée selon le réseau de
neurones générateurs on peut ensuite
déterminer la probabilité de la banque
de données d'image au multipliant ainsi
les probabilités obtenu pour les
différentes images et ça c'est en
principe ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
calculer la probabilité des données
sachant une configuration des paramètres
du réseau générateurs malheureusement
c'est un calcul un faisable en pratique
surtout si
images sont de très haute résolution en
effet si on a un million de pixels alors
le temps qu'il faudra pour reconstituer
exactement une image donnée sera de
l'ordre de 10 puissance 1 million ce qui
est bien pire qu'un nombre
cryptographiques
petit aparté les nombreux
cryptographique on va bientôt en parler
sur la chaîne string theory
bref il nous faut faire encore une
approximation du calcul bayésiens et
bien l'idée dé gagnent c'est d'utiliser
un réseau adverse arial pour calculer
une approximation de cette probabilité
impossible à calculer autrement en cela
les gars ne font partie d'une famille
plus large d'inférence bayésienne dit
sans vraisemblance pour des raisons un
peu obscur qui agace un peu le buzz est
en moi cette famille contient aussi par
exemple les à proximité jeune
compétition et les paramétrique belge en
direct la croûte et ces derniers ont
d'ailleurs a été utilisé dans la thèse
un excellent youtuber scientifique
après c'est pas parce qu'une thèse
contient le mot b jeunes que c'est
forcément une bonne thèse mais bon dans
le cas de sébastien ça parle aussi de
ses créateurs donc si tu montes
ceci dit ce qui distingue les gagnent
des autres inférences bas et viennent
sans vraisemblance c'est que parce qu'il
s'agit de réseaux de neurones segan se
prête très bien à l'apprentissage des
paramètres guidés par des gradients
autrement dit illégal semble bien se
tenir à l'intersection entre
approximations de la formule deux pays''
et optimisation des paramètres par
descente de gradient et ça ça fait que
je parie centraux flipper que les gan
joueront un rôle central dans les yeux
du futur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernière fois en a pas
réseau très profond et comment réussir à
les entraîner malgré notamment
l'évanescence du gradient qui est le
phénomène observé de façon empirique et
qu'il anticipe également très facilement
avec la zone dans tes oreilles tout
simple qui vient du fait que il ya un
système multiplicatif que l'on observe
notamment au niveau du gradient lorsque
l'on à des réseaux profond et d'une
succession de beaucoup de multiplication
conduit à une croissance exponentielle
qui peut conduire un explosion
exponentielle ou une évanescence
exponentielle et benoît quand on nous
demande quel est l'effet des fonctions
de l'activation sur cette évanescence
exponentielle du gradient et bien si
vous faites un petit peu le calcul vous
verrez que lorsqu'on remonte le gradient
et bien ce qui va compter ça va être la
dérivée de la fonction d'activation à
son niveau d'activation données et du
coup on pourrait se dire que des
fonctions de l'activation ou les
gradients sont importants vont conduire
plus une explosion exponentielle du
gradient alors que les cas où la dérivée
du gradient est faible qu à ce monde bus
à une évanescence exponentielle du
gratin du coup à partir de là on peut se
dire qu'avoir fait des fonctions
d'activation qui sont très plateau en
certains endroits
typiquement lorsque je prends des
sigmoïde en fait elles sont très plate
dès qu'on s'écarte un petit peu du
centre ou quand je prends des fonctions
directif ailleurs ligne henry unit c'est
complètement plat à gauche pour éviter
ce genre de cas on pourra remplacer les
rectifier leur ligne 8 par des fonctions
valeur absolue je crois que c'est un nom
spéciale en terminologie machine
learning mais bon c'est juste la
fonction valeur absolue et équipements
et cette fonction valeur absolue - sa
dérive est toujours égale à 1 ou qu'on
se place et du coup on peut dire qu'il
aura jamais un gardien qui deviendra 0
après avoir traversé avoir peut-être
remonter cette fonction d'activation
ccdh il ya également des défauts avoir
des fonctions de l'activation comme ça
qui sont en fait sans borne qui peuvent
prendre des valeurs aussi grande que
l'on veut parce que du coup les signaux
qui sortent de ces motions d'activation
sont également un bon guide sont sans
borne goût une synapse pourrait avoir
tout le poids du gradient et le reste
pour avoir un effet négligeable et du
coup l'apprentissage pourrait être
synapse par synapse et aucun tweet
ivement c'est un truc qui paraît très
insatisfaisant puisque ça ferait
beaucoup de libération pour un apprenti
pour l'apprentissage
d'ailleurs pour régler ce genre de
problème il ya des techniques qui sont
utilisés comme la baci normalisation ou
la normalisation du bac je sais pas trop
pourquoi s'appelle battu d'ailleurs mais
l'idée c'est vraiment que la sortie le
signal de sortie dans une synapse qui
traverse une synapse ce signal de sortie
doit jamais prendre des valeurs trop
grande ni trop petite
idéalement en fait ce genre de signaux
qui sortent doit être toujours à peu
près du même ordre de grandeur
et ça en fait c'est vrai du signal à
travers assignables c'est aussi vrai des
poids à synaptique
c'est aussi vrai des fonctions de
l'activation donc plus généralement en
fait il semble que les réseaux de
neurones qui apprennent bien ce sont des
réseaux de neurones ou tout l'autre
réseau apprend à peu près au même rythme
tous les paramètres sont a appris à peu
près au même rythme et en particulier
l'évanescence du gradient est un vrai
problème puisque une certaine manière
les couches profondes apprennent
beaucoup plus vite mende et des normes
du gradient beaucoup plus grandes que
les couches initial et donc il semble en
tout cas empiriquement et a sans doute
ça va pouvoir se justifier
théoriquement même si j'ai pas vu passer
de papier qui ont paraît il semble qu'un
bon apprentissage en apprentissage ou
tout le réseau apprend ensemble à peu
près au même rythme et où toutes les
informations sont à peu près du même
monde même ordre de grandeur partout
dans le réseau ça pour dire que les
fonctions qu'il devienne pas un moment
pose problème parce qu'elle donne plus
un risque de débats naissance du
gradient mais les fonctions qui sont
sans borne pose également problème
puisqu'elle risque de causer des signaux
qui sont par endroits beaucoup plus fort
que dans d'autres endroits ce qui est il
sera également néfaste à l'apprentissage
du réseau d'une certaine manière il ya
un peu un équilibre à trouver dans l'
architecture globale du réseau pour que
tout le réseau apprennent ensemble et à
ma connaissance
à part cette idée un peu intuitif il n'y
a pas vraiment de bonnes recherches en
tout cas théoriques sur cette question
adrien de cause lui demande s'il ne
serait pas possible de créer une machine
ou un algorithme qui générerait des
algorithmes capables de bien apprendre
de résoudre les premiers apprentissages
ça c'est un truc qui j'ai pas beaucoup
étudié
déjà désireux en gros qui sont capables
de générer des murs rire ou du moins des
meilleurs architecture de réseaux de
neurones qu'un humain ne serait capable
de le faire
typiquement une des idées qui est
d'ailleurs été proposée par turing en
1950 c'est d'effectuer un apprentissage
génétiques sur les meilleurs
architecture de réseaux de neurones donc
avec des idées des algorithmes
génétiques j'en ai déjà parlé plusieurs
fois dans les commentaires des vidéos
malheureusement j'ai pas préparé de
vidéos séries sur l'île telle qu'elle
est mais l'idée de base c'est en gros
d'avoir plusieurs formes d'architecturé
plusieurs paramètres de ces
architectures et d'essayer de mélanger
temps en temps certains paramètres
donc ça revient un petit peu à faire des
croisements génétiques entre certains à
certaines architectures de réseau à
regarder un petit peu comment elles
performent
et puis ton temps à supprimer de
l'ensemble de la population de
l'architecturé de réseaux de neurones
les architectures qui sont moins
performantes que d'autres vraiment ça
revient un peu à simuler finalement la
manière dont le cerveau tellement humain
a fini par acquérir les capacités qu'il
a acquise
finalement c'est cet algorithme
génétique qui a permis à la sélection
naturelle et à la nature de créer des
machines à penser aussi performante que
le cerveau non
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
c'était le dernier sur les architectures
de réseaux de neurones c'est aussi je
consulte plus intéressant est le loin
que cette idée l'architecturé de réseau
adverse à rioz dans les deux prochains
épisodes on va revenir sur des questions
plus théorique on va se demander
notamment qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils le
succès des réseaux de neurones profond
qu est ce qu il ya de façon théorique de
justifier le fait que plus un réseau et
profond plus il est adapté pour
apprendre et pour bien comprendre le
monde qui l'entouré en particulier le
prochain épisode est un épisode qui va
explorer les relations entre le diplôme
ni et les fractales voilà le truc
vraiment trop classe du machine learning
électrique d'armes entre classes de la
géométrie
on verra ça la semaine prochaine si vous
aimez cette vidéo pensez à le lac est le
commentaire de partager frontalière vous
abonner pour perfusion d'épisodes merci
au type colorant et j'espère que vous
serez là la prochaine foire du carré des
jalles rights watch
vous êtes